hey guys Pete Peppers here this video will
contain spoilers
HBO released some new information today that confirms a
popular fan theory
that's been around for years
so if you don't want to know in the show
who
Jon Snow's parents are you want to stop
watching right now
alright so from the very first season of
the HBO show Game of Thrones it's been
a mystery as to who
Jon Snow's parents are.  he's a snow
which means he's a bastard and
everything we know about Ned his father
seems to not be in line with him going
off to war and fathering a bastard
so that there's been a mystery when John
first goes to the wall in this scene
here whenever he talks to his father his
father says next time they meet he'll
tell him about his mother and of course
Ned dies at the end of season one
and they never see each other again
so in the season six finale it's finally
been confirmed and we see Jon Snow's
birth and all this around all the
different things that are going on at
the Tower of joy
but if you weren't following the
theories are you haven't really looked
into it too deeply you might not really
understand what this all means. to make
things a little bit clearer HBO release
this infographic today that shows all
the different connections between the
characters
there's a lot of different information
on this I don't know what you call i
guess you know this graph and what's
really important as far as this video's
concern is just the actual parentage and
connections between a few of the
different characters so if we if we just
take away all the other people and we
look at John his parents and his
connection to net we can see that Jon
was born between Lyanna Stark and Rhaegar
Targaryen Lyanna is Ned's younger sister
and Danaerys is Rhaegars younger
sister
so whenever you think about the
connection between Joh
and Danaerys - Danaerys would actually be his aunt
so you there is another line here that
you can see that's the the purple dashed
line and it says "abducted" and we'll get
into that later but the other thing that
i wanted to mention here is that Jon is
then in a sense the blood of fire and ice
since the Starks are from the north and
the Targaryens are associated with
dragons and fire
so one more thing that's worth looking
at before we get into the history of
who his parents are is that
there is no red line that connects Lyanna
and Rhaegar. the red line would show like
it goes from Lyanna to Robert because
she was betrothed to Robert
they were never wed but it also
indicates at least as far as the show is
concerned that Lyanna and Rhaegar were never married either
that would indicate that John is still a
bastard except for now he's a Targaryen
bastard
instead of stark bastard
Prince Rhaegar Targaryen was the eldest
son of the Mad King Arys the second
Targaryen being the eldest son he was
the crown prince of Dragonstone
and he was also the prince
that was supposed to succeed his father
on the Iron Throne
we have several different descriptions
of Rhaegar in the books and he said to
be tall good-looking dark indigo eyes
which is a common Targaryen trait with
long silver hair
I won't go too deeply into his history for
this video but we get a lot of different
things when the Danaerys asks Sir
Barristen Selmy about her
eldest brother and we find out that he's
a good he's a good fighter but he's also a
really intelligent person and a talented
musician as well
we also know that he was somewhat
bookish and became somewhat obsessed
with prophecy at one point and he was
really interested in the idea of the
prince that was promised
so basically he was looking for this
combination of a child born of fire and
ice
he was married to Elia Martell princess
of Dorne
she gave him two children but after the
second was unable to have anymore
so this inability to have more children
may have preceded the events that went
on at the the great tourney at Harrenhal
Prince Rhaegar won the tourney and
when it came time to crown the queen of
love and beauty he did not choose his
own wife instead he picked Lyanna Stark.
Lyanna was betrothed to Robert
Baratheon so this basically
set in action the events that led to
Robert's rebellion which took the
Targaryens off of the Iron Throne
during the battle of the Trident Robert
Baratheon defeated Rhaegar, killing him
with his war hammer in single combat which basically was the decisive military
battle in the rebellion
so since history is written by the
victors
the story has always been that Rhaegar
had kidnapped Lyanna taking her away
and having raped her
We hear that story again and again from
different characters throughout the
books and  in the TV series but there is a
lot of evidence that makes it seem like
that wasn't probably the case
Lyanna seems to be a willing participant
and they seem to run away together to
have a child rather than
this abduction story that everyone sort
of perpetuated on the Baratheon side
they run away to the south to the
tower of joy in Dorne and spent several
months together there until Rhaegar
left to join the battle
of the Trident
he left the pregnant liana behind
with three of his top Kingsguard to
protect her and the royal child and
basically she's there until Ned and his
his friends ride south to rescue
her and that's the Tower of joy scene
that we see in the TV show
so after Ned arrives at the Tower of
joy and slays Sir Arthur
Dayne with the help of Howland Redd he
goes inside to find Lyanna bleeding
after giving birth
if Robert finds out he will kill him
you know he will
you have to protect him
Promise me Ned
(baby crying)
so this is a big deal for Ned and it
really defines a lot of
who he is
throughout the story obviously he had
just married Catelyn whenever he went to
fight in the war and before he left he
got her with child with
Rob. so he barely knew her in
a way.  she was actually betrothed
to his brother Brandon so the way things
worked out he left and then he came back
with Jon Snow and he couldn't really
explain to her because there was too
much risk as he made this promise
so it basically just was a secret that
he had to keep and couldn't tell any one
so we've already mentioned a lot about
Lyanna Stark and the fact that she was
Ned's younger sister that she was
betrothed to Robert and she basically
was the catalyst for Robert starting his
rebellion
we also know that she was beautiful it's
said that she was considered beautiful
by all and we also know that because
Rhaegar crowned her the
queen of love and beauty
also we know that she was a skilled
rider
it's said that she rode a horse like a
Northman and that Ned actually compares
her an appearance and sort of her
tomboyishness to Arya
so out of all this the stark children
you know Arya seems to have the the
closest comparison and Ned actually
says that
Lyanna probably would have carried
a sword if their father had
approved of it
so that is the story of Jon Snow's
parents
there's a bunch of interesting stuff
that goes along with this and if you
look at this a little bit closer there
is really a lot of neat little
things the way people are connected
one thing that is interesting is that
whenever service he goes to see Maggy
the Frog in that prophecy when she asked
what she married the Prince she's
actually talking about Prince Rhaegar.
Lord Tywin was the hand of the king and
he was hoping to marry off
Cersei to Rhaegar.  it didn't work out
that way but that's who she grew up
basically being in love with and so we
know she never really
loved Robert and Robert always had love
Lyanna so basically Robert never loved
Cersei and certainly never loved Robert
and they both love the two people who
got together and are John's parents so
that you know it's a it's a big mystery
that's finally been at least as far as a
TV shows concern solved
Jon Snow is a Targaryen at least by
blood
I'm not a hundred percent sure it's
going to go that way in the books I mean
it's pretty likely now I was always in
the camp of or at least I i ended up in
the camp of our + l equals D and you
know the shardene stuff but you know r+
l equals je regarde policy on equals
John always made a lot of sense and
we'll see what happens in the books we
don't really know it's not guarantee
that it will be the same so i hope you
liked this video please give it a like
and subscribe to my channel i'll be
talking to you soon